so we have to start there with your top
five sports movies and they have to be
in order
oh that's tough and ordered yes cause
you know the cop out is just to say them
all you gotta rank this word i gotta
rank the sports movies okay i'm going
with
number one
oh man uh white man can't jump
great
great start number two i'm gonna go with
any given sunday
three i'm going with sandlot
um
[Music]
for
i'm gonna go with
remember the titans and five i'm going
to hardball bias yeah i got to pick
harper yeah there is a big one missing
but it is all opinion there was no he
got game oh man yes yeah see i'm gonna
save you there there's no he got game
yes all right i'll swap
i swap remember the titans and he got
gang okay yeah
all right are you missing any other big
ones
i mean are you like a
are you like a major league are you a
jerry maguire are you any of
uh
they don't really rank i was gonna say
space jam one yeah what i'm saying just
as a straight classic uh but
i don't know field the dreams was i
guess
that counts right yeah that counts yeah
such an unrealistic plot mighty ducks
mighty ducks
yes but your list is solid so i'll take
that and start there and yeah you passed
that test
you